the hr lady who i had become friends
with
she was really sad and disappointed that
she had to lay me off and i was like
to anyone working in the film industry
sajada
if they had to put a time limit on
becoming a working professional
what would that be
never put a time limit on
art i would say
because i i have found throughout my
years there have been
a lot of my friends and acquaintances
that i've been in touch with or met in
acting class or
through writing
and anyone who puts a time limit on it
such as
if i don't do this thing
within a year or if i don't do
this particular goal within two or three
years then i'm gonna go back to
xyz which could be anything which could
be in my case you know i have an
engineering degree so if i were to say
that okay i need to get
to direct a studio film within five
years
or else i'm gonna go back to engineering
i feel like the universe hears that and
listens to that and says okay you have
this backup plan so
it won't give you that first thing that
you want
and i just think it's a everybody says
this but it's a marathon not a sprint
and i've noticed that you know there are
goals that i hope to have wished to
achieve by this point which i haven't
achieved but i'm enjoying the journey
and the journey has been so much fun so
it's all about waking up in the morning
being excited that you actually get to
pursue your dream
and
enjoying the moment that you're in
whether it's
oh you get to go pitch to a certain
executive or studio or network today or
whether it's you get to go have coffee
with a certain writer that you
uh are inspired by
and and just taking those little
experiences and making that exciting and
making that a goal as opposed to
i need to sell a show by this date or i
need to
be a series regular by this date um so i
truly believe you can't put
a time limit on your dreams
when you were getting that engineering
degree was that your plan a at the time
no
that was always my plan b
so
i
i'll take it back to my childhood where
was always dancing singing
writing
acting
but i was also
really good at math and science it came
easy to me
and
when i entered middle school i started
doing plays when i entered high school i
started doing musicals and i was always
dancing every week
and my parents were very supportive and
they would
come to guys and dolls every night and
bring a bouquet of flowers and
cheer for me
and it was always really exciting but
then i was also taking ap physics ap bio
ap chem ap calculus and killing it on
those exams as well
so
my plan my master plan i started
thinking about when i was about 16 or 17
and i said to myself okay i can't move
to hollywood at the age of 17. so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go get this
engineering degree
and
take it from there and then move out
to la
after i graduate
and so i went to get my engineering
degree and in the meantime continued to
do plays and musicals and continue to
write in college i took a semester of
screenwriting i took a semester of
playwriting
and
then i the summer before my senior year
of college i interned at a company
called accenture which is a global
consulting firm really big name
um they're on par with deloitte and
touch and ernst and young
and
had a fun summer interning there and at
the end of that summer i was offered a
full-time job so this was even before
going into my senior year so they asked
me
where i wanted to work what city i
wanted to work in and i said
los angeles
and i said los angeles and they said
great that's where we'll send you after
you graduate so i went into my senior
year
already having a job
and
as soon as i graduated i moved to la
on accenture's dime and then i was on a
salary
so i was making a shitload of money
at the age of 20 pretty much and
the thing about consulting is you never
have to
work unless you're placed on a project
so basically that entire year that i
worked there i was only on a project for
about two weeks and i was the worst
accenture employee you could ever think
of and i just had all my phone calls go
to my cell phone never went into work
and in the meantime what i was doing was
meeting with agents i was going to
acting class i was
getting headshots i was auditioning
and at the end of that year working for
accenture
i got laid off which was also
awesome
because i got severance i got
unemployment
and for about eight to ten months i
believe i was just yeah i was just like
making money and that's when i
ramped up my auditioning
and about
i don't know months later i booked three
national commercials in a row so that's
when
my
professional career started i believe
and in the meantime i was still writing
scripts still writing shorts
writing short stories poems songs etc
and
that's how i got into acting but it was
all part of the master plan of like okay
i don't want to
be a burden to my parents
i want to be able to support myself
what's the best way i can do that okay
let's take this job in this other field
which is kind of
the perfect day job to be honest and
then
i moved out here and did it on my own
how did you get word that you were being
laid off
what was hilarious was i was like i told
you i was a terrible employee so it was
a round of layoffs a bunch of employees
were getting laid off at the same time
and i was one of them i came in and the
hr lady who i had become friends with
she was really sad and disappointed that
she had to lay me off and i was like
i'm good
please don't waste your emotions on me
and
and it was it was a good day
how many plan b's have you had while
you've been here in los angeles i've had
zero plan b's i
i've had the day jobs which have been
really fun actually i think there was
always a dream of me even being an
engineer
the dream that you see
in tv and in the movies of an aspiring
actor is
they're working at a restaurant or
they're working
uh as a hostess somewhere and that's
what i did and i had so much fun because
i was finally surrounded by creative
people because everyone
working in the restaurant business in
los angeles generally tends to be an
artist and that is their day job so i
had a blast i worked at a diner i worked
at a fancy steakhouse and then i
realized that i really loved hostessing
so i was working the front of desk at
these places and it was really fun i was
meeting all these people working at
really hot
trendy spots in la
and making friends and i never
considered that a plan b that was always
just me making friends and
making my home in los angeles surrounded
by the people that i finally wanted to
be surrounded by
yeah those can be fun jobs i know they
can be stressful though too especially
if you think that
there is no time limit for them i think
they're romantic for a while but
there's also a trap of being in them too
long i think that can really weigh
people down
how do you handle or how did you at that
time well-meaning comments maybe from
family and friends
um that we're like that's great you know
we love that you're still pursuing like
you're dancing and acting but
you're gonna need something more stable
or you can't make real money from this
things like that
well coming from
an indian immigrant family you get those
comments a little bit more maybe than
usual and
i
just handled it by i'd be like well this
is the money that i made on the
commercial and so i'll just like book
another commercial and we'll see what's
what happens obviously it's not that
easy you don't just go out and book
another commercial
but i was making steady progress
so
it did
something that my my dad would say was
why don't you go to
get a masters in acting or it's always
about more education
and and i was like well you know i'm
taking upright citizens brigade classes
and i'm taking really fun
um other drama type acting classes and
i'm taking sketch writing classes and
and everything i write like i get a
little bit better every script i write
is a little bit better than the one
before
and
so i just really had to explain to my
parents like this is what i'm doing i'm
continuously studying i'm continuously
growing and i don't necessarily need to
go do a master's program somewhere
so you showed them like here's here's a
residual check or here's whatever the
buyout check that i got for this
commercial and
and maybe that quelled some of their
anxiety yeah i think it was more about
can you pay the rent can you
pay for your food are you eating healthy
are you out on the street somewhere
and and so it was mostly about
just having a stable life as opposed to
i think their version of the hollywood
dream was more
people living on the streets and and
doing shady things to succeed and i was
like you know that's in your soap operas
that you watch
but that's not real life hollywood
there's just a lot of people who are
working really hard to achieve their
dreams and continuously growing in terms
of their art and that's what i want to
do